james james bond est de retour pour
sauver le monde le destin nous réunit à
nouveau le célèbre agent secret doit
sortir de sa retraite pour retrouver un
scientifique été kidnappés mouret peut
attendre le 25e film de la franchise
réunit tous les éléments qui ont fait
son succès course poursuite à couper le
souffle gadget et véhicules futuristes
et paysages spectaculaires mais on y
présente aussi au jazz band plus
complexe et plus humain pour la première
fois on le voit ressentir des choses
qu'ils font un peu sortir de ses gonds
qui lui font ressentir de la rancoeur de
la paranoïa de l'amertume de la colère
de la tristesse bref c'est toutes sortes
d'émotions qu'on n'avait pas encore vu
et que daniel craig interprète avec
beaucoup de conviction soit on n'est pas
très indulgente avec les hommes qui se
prennent pour dieu face à james brown
l'organisation criminelle spectre et le
redoutable safin interprété par l'acteur
oscarisé rami malek c'est intéressant de
voir qu'il ya toujours un effet de
miroir avec james bond comme si les
vilains finalement était vraiment son
côté sombre qui se matérialisait devant
lui
mourir peut attendre et les pilotes des
cinq films dans lesquels daniel craig
ont interprété le célèbre agent 007
quinze ans durant lesquels james bande a
considérablement évolué c'est étonnant
parce qu'il est moins machos et plus
viril il est moins baveux mais plus
drôle il a été je crois le james bond le
plus humain celui auquel on pouvait
peut-être le plus se raccrocher en
termes d'émotions de sentiments il a été
aussi peut-être le james bond le plus
réaliste
les héroïnes aussi obtient des rôles
plus riche que ce soit nos 1000 un
nouvel agent 007 la docteure madeleine
swan ou la jambe de la cia paloma les
femmes qui est james bond va croiser ce
sont des femmes qui sont fortes sont et
des femmes qui sont absolument égal à
lui
mourir peut attendre mais les fans de
l'agent 007 et les propriétaires de
salles de cinéma eux étaient impatients
la sortie a été plusieurs fois repoussée
à cause de la pandémie je pense que les
gens le public va être au rendez vous
pour aller voir ce film là d'autant plus
que depuis la réouverture des salles on
l'a pas encore eu ce grand blockbuster
rassembleur familiale divertissant et
james bond lecture on réussit pas bien
qu'ils aient plus de 2h40 d'en mourir
peut attendre on ne s'ennuie pas mais
dès le générique terminé on sait qu on
s'ennuiera de daniel craig dans la peau
de james bond ici chartier nabi
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]